ce
puzzle à ses besoins days
avec taqa
cobra tu
attends pas il dit
tu veux savoir où tu es
vous parle fantin oui toi pu lire sur
les lèvres oui d'accord est-ce que je
peux t'aider
qu'est ce que tu veux on aime le klingon
tous côtés disent qu'on a bien
évidemment alors où
en haute montagne alors là ce soit ou
pas 15 9
bon à moi oui justement
notre
nom à tabac à la barre
haut notre dame et les bleus ne tombait
pas d'être adopté
dassieu
mondial-98 et chansons
et pour au four est un pur
saurez
vous pourrez pour sa fourrure en
ânonnant pour aimer son expression que
choisir
pour copuler
copuler attend non mais non pour moi moi
je vais pas copine avec toi maman papa
nous débat à m'amuser musée bas avant
d'être
définitif
qui aiguise fruits 1 défaite danseuses
danseurs
danseuses dans sa
réserve
deux rues
et tu marches jusqu'à
la fin tu marches
jusqu'à sainte catherine oui vous êtes
perdus
ok je peux aller sur un village d'al
fida
laspougeas village people 3 mt non non
non on prend le comprenais pas elle est
un acte j'ai un accent plus trouver un
acteur
pour moi
on
a peut-être eu j'espère english attack
parle français a lorient on parle la
même langue car lille où je parle
français - où est ok ok
[Musique]